in league of legends not every champion
is meant to put on a show in the game's
early days 80 carries in particular were
used to playing safely positioning
carefully in team fights and waiting for
the right chance to carry the day but
one champion broke the mold he gave adcs
the spotlight and let them pick their
own moment to shine
oh
he kissed him
he inspired the game's player base and
throughout the game's history pro
players saw something in ezreal the
prodigal explorer too and it's up on
baker but teddy is alive and teddy's
trying to go 1v3 he gets another one and
he's gotta get another reason
man teddy is so gigantic it was the
opportunity to grasp perfection and
wield it against their opponents oh
[Applause]
these mechanical gods crave the skill
expression ezreal enabled and the
champion fit them like a glove and
they're looking to make their way to the
quarterfinals do they run fast enough
this is the story of ezreal
hey everyone before we get into the
video we wanted to let you know that
we've worked with bose to create their
new rule the quiet videos which follow
key storylines at worlds here's a sneak
preview
check out the link below for more rule
the quiet videos and thanks to bose for
sending over these awesome quiet comfort
earbuds now back to the story of ezreal
at the beginning of league of legends 80
carries had a certain archetype they
were based around auto attacks many of
them could augment their auto attacks
and some had other tools for spacing out
opponents like snares slows or movement
abilities and they pretty much all built
attack damage after all that's what the
ad stands for so when ezreal was
released in march 2010 he had a couple
clear differences from the usual
template for one he was built from the
ground up for damage specifically the
kit's low cooldown skill shots
encouraged players to push their
accuracy to the limit to make the best
use of his passive trait which increased
his attack speed when a damaging ability
landed of course other adcs had skill
shots but none of them needed to hit
them as consistently and frequently as
ezreal
is right on to scarra he is shredding so
as a diamond right now the first kills
full house
they are still coming
off
[Applause]
[Applause]
for this
[Applause]
so in short cast lots of skill shots hit
lots of skill shots get attack speed and
weave in plenty of auto attacks between
those skill shots all while playing
fairly close to the front of the team
fight due to his short auto attack range
i think that if you get down to the
brass tacks of what makes ezreal amazing
in competitive play is that if you're
not very good at league of legends
ezreal feels like the worst champion in
the universe
that's it unlike other ad carries though
ezreal didn't have a slow root or stun
instead he had a short range flash that
also did damage if you overextended the
consequences were dire and he comes back
into this lane might be a good time for
faker to get back as a hook gonna land
onto manu here down in that bottom lane
but piglet gonna dive in there cave
julie gonna fall from this one piglet
picks up that kill pray
he's not got him though pray going super
low and he will fall big look picks up
the double i know our analyst test is
gonna have to something to say about
that bottom lane mechanics because prey
missed a couple shots there and then
didn't even finish off the support trade
and in much the same way that it was
easy to detect a badass real play a
truly skilled player turned the
performance into a dance of death a
light show for the audience the jumping
from impact the equalizer lays out the
red carpet but they're all off of it
already they've entered into the fight
royals hellfires are just getting
demolished uzi on the outside trying to
do what he can but it's not going to be
enough he's chased into the base and has
wiped him for the ace the quadra when
you see instant cleanse into arcane
shift into managing to land all of your
skill shirts fade away
mystic shots you know all of that sort
of control the fact that ezreal
throughout his entire time no matter
what build he'd gone it's always very
impactful when you see him do these
things ezreal didn't only capture the
hearts of the competitive audience he
became a staple of the game he was the
first champion in league of legends to
receive a champion spotlight video and
ezreal's character two parts anime
protagonist one part indiana jones
became a favorite as the game exploded
in global popularity he received the
game's first ultimate skin and was the
first champion to have 13 different
skins ezreal's potential for flashy
plays and devil may care attitude earned
him fans across league of legends his
unique blend of on hits energy and short
skill shot cooldowns meant that even
though he often still built ad items he
had a greater emphasis on mana
and on mechanical precision there was
just one problem back in the early days
it wasn't clear exactly how he would fit
into the game's developing meta until
one legendary 80 carry player showed us
just how high the ceiling truly was
i think that you can't mention
ezreal first without mentioning that wei
zhao did it first
he was the god of ezreal and this goes
back 10 years right so
has to be said in league of legends
early days international competition was
different it was a time where standalone
tournaments flourished and were unique
opportunities to test the region's medal
against each other during those first
couple years there were a lot of
candidates for the greatest 80 carry in
the game but for many china's wei zhao
was the finest mechanical player at the
position
and he agreed at least in the west a lot
of people think that you and doublelift
are the two best 80 carries in the world
uh are you
the best 80 carry in the world are you
better than doublelift i think i'm
better as an id carry
as part of world elite wei zhao became
perhaps china's first true international
law superstar and it was a reputation
built on excellence both in lane and in
team fights it's fitting then that wei
zhao was also the first player to truly
push ezreal to his limits oh my goodness
this could be so so close heal that true
shot barrage so much damage wait shout
out plays him completely out
and now comes insect to clean it up oh
it's close can he do it he does where's
your what a hero at ipl 5 world elite
faced the strongest competition the
world had to offer in the grand finals
they toppled fnatic and weizhau's ezreal
was a big reason why
damage and here they come around the
side and rayton having to flash over the
top of there
[Applause]
oh there's the exhaust as well the
second coming down for lulu what a start
for world elite and the ward gives their
position away there's three members of
fnatic split away here they're not too
sure which way to run it's gonna be the
chop ragnarok coach and rated it's gonna
get around there's gonna be ragnarok
straight in there soulmate and that is
gonna be a free bar and there's just
nothing but nanny can do about that
fnatic sent two members into the bottom
lane to try to kill olaf tell me again
with sp being the split push master just
gives them this free baron there's
nothing they can do against it oh my god
look at wei zhao's items infinity edge
phantom dancer last whisper and an
executioner's calling that's a build cap
right now it multiplies so well with
what he's doing with nunu right now this
dive is if they fight here even if they
tank the turret it's gonna be so hard
for fnatic to stay in it world elite
hanging outside of that base here we go
they're going to put some pressure down
charm actually lands on to chow mein
there comes the ultimate out of zaira as
well oh world elite gonna back away
messiah's right in the middle as he pops
us on yeah here comes the rest of the
team the unstoppable force came out but
it wasn't really enough they do take
down messiah but everybody else is in
trouble soulmate completely tanking
reckless down and rated in trouble
they're all caught out by the tower pika
have to use his ultimate to try and
avoid the damage such a triple kill for
weight zhao though he is stomping
through the pekka goes down it's a
goldsmith acer let's hear it ladies and
gentlemen team world elite the winners
of the ign pro league five here in las
vegas fantastic performance world elite
didn't become a dominant dynasty like we
see from korea in the years to come and
wei zhao retired relatively early in
2014 after a series of disappointing
results and a mischance at worlds
qualification but if you followed league
back then and you wanted to see the
cutting edge of ezreal play
you didn't need to look further than
china's original adc god but every
champion that has like a a sick play or
a uh a damaged ceiling that we don't
know about there is a player to find
that out and
you know what happened with orianna as
well you know a player like uh like
faker demonstrated that this champion
isn't too hard but you have to put
things in the context of the amount of
experience people have and wei zhao is
the one that showed us first just how
much damage ezreal can do in a short
period of time in 2015 as korea cemented
itself as a league of legends powerhouse
it was only fitting that two of its
greatest adcs found an outlet for their
mechanics in ezreal but despite their
shared homeland and position
bang and deft approached the champion
quite differently as part of sk telecom
t1 bang played ezreal in a much
different context than wei zhao he could
carry games for his team but unlike wei
zhao he didn't have to because he was on
the greatest team in league of legends
history so throughout skt's golden age
and beyond bang played a style of ezreal
that was more akin to a pocket ace
sometimes even when he made good
individual plays he could count on his
team to make better ones and enable
ezreal's incredible damage in the
process trying to dance with that pulp
from ezreal is incredibly dangerous you
can see how much respect they're giving
bang right now oh yeah 37 minutes into
this game this guy is nuts oh duke went
back
and it's a 4b5 right now gorilla very
low smeb looking for a way to come from
the side but again banks such a big
threat it's not stopping them from going
out to this parent though oh here we go
coming in smab does some damage he's all
over bengi meanwhile the counter engaged
faker comes in and alts himself duke
getting into the back lines too kuro
still okay banky wow bang managed to
take out snap back back into this fight
he could win it for skt and now banging
the rest of us holy cow
[Applause]
sk telecom they find a way man other
times he saw opportunities others might
not and he never hesitated to take them
they can take a lot if skt get a little
sloppy here and you know walk towards
one of those brush where they don't have
vision oh
oh indeed hoonie looks like he's going
down the red buff is ticking away
and bang is dominating
this sweat cool guys don't look at
explosions
rather than push himself to play
aggressively in lane even before ezreal
hit his two-item power spike and with
legendary support wolf at his side to
initiate favorable fights he was able to
take the highest percentage plays while
keeping himself safe now the way bang
played uh ezra was a little bit
different because i felt like there was
a time where bang was put on ezreal judy
that it was mainly so that wolf could go
and kill people and when bang was on
ezreal he was just not able to be killed
what bang had in
you know the years when skt were at the
height of their dominance was just
obscene levels of consistency and i
think a champion like ezreal you're
consistent on ezreal means you're
landing a lot of a lot of skill shots
and doing a lot of abilities in exactly
the way that you need to so that's why
he stands out to me while he may not
have been the flashiest ezreal bang
wasn't really trying to be on a team
like skt he didn't have to stomp his
lane to win the game he just had to
ensure they didn't lose it standing in
contrast to bang's steady hand was the
flashy deft who first made a name for
himself in 2014 as part of the lck's
samsung blue he was someone who relished
team fights and found ways to embarrass
even the toughest opponents and def
comes into the back lines arcane
shifting into the base to get two kills
already donna way deep into the base he
wants a bit of the action as well one
kill for him a triple kill now for depth
and that is a clean ace and that has got
to be the game but after a semi-final
exit at worlds 2014 to sister team
samsung white deft did something
unexpected he was one of several korean
stars to move to the lpl for the 2015
season when he accepted an offer from
edward gaming deft before he actually
left korea he was known more as a team
fight positioning player he was playing
things like the twitch he's always been
a fantastic late game carry player
but he was known more for late game
positioning not necessarily for
aggressive laning and in china he
changed sure he still had the team fight
prowess that had made him a star but as
he teamed up with mako to become one of
the most dangerous bot lanes in the game
he took on more of the responsibility to
pressure his opponents early and that
change included ezreal a champion that
had a reputation for a limited early
game and a heavy reliance on items wow
the damage coming out of death very real
and you see the slow up how useful it is
that's beard just under a cliff taking
so much damage just from xiaohu alone
cora diving into the background and jeff
actually kills sync dream there off to
the cyber huey gonna dive in a good off
from maker will disengage him current
enough into the background on the tail
def going very aggressive forward and
correct is taking up so much damage blue
airshield keeping everyone in place tail
will go down next as well and edg a
beautiful fight will finish in an ace
yeah clean ace as well no one going down
def the star of that team fight able to
keep up with everyone slowed everyone
the aoe and his prowess with the
champion continued even after he
returned to play in korea in 2017. it
feels like all of us have to win but
kings aren't going to fight anyway don't
want to make the perspective and double
talk
as tim is gonna try to get away from
this one but does go down and with the
two carries gone
as you mentioned it looks like kamalia
going to maybe be gone in this fight as
a triple kill watching death play he was
just able to get more able to get more
out of the champion and i think that
it's good champion design
when you can have a player managed to
stand out like that when we'd already
been through a lot of competitive years
of this game this champion had been out
since the very beginning and we were
still seeing that personal flair
actually being represented in a champion
that you know everyone should have so
many games on and so many hours of play
time on wei zhao bang and deft showed
ezreal's potential in the hands of a
mechanical mastermind but despite the
potential for burst damage and outplays
ezreal wasn't always a viable pick and
there were times where he virtually
disappeared from the meta whether it was
outright disasters like the juggernaut
patch or just firm metas like arden
sensor the prodigal explorer sometimes
wasn't able to discover a way to get
drafted in a role where the meta often
had an outsized impact there were also
times when the champion's interaction
with certain mana or on-hit items made
him an incredibly powerful pick even
making mid lane appearances like during
the pre-nerf runeglave ezreal period
baker still no flash score coming in
takes some turret hits they're going to
try to slow him faker just arcane shifts
away oh the enemies embrace comes out
peekaboo gets picked off by that true
shot barrage nice bait actually bringing
him right into the clutches of banky and
skt not done quite yet here comes marin
up from the bottom line faker had more
damage on the dog nice head but
pulverize another kill but after a 2018
visual makeover and gameplay rework
ezreal was ready to continue being one
of the most exciting champions at his
position time for a true display of
skill
in modern league of legends a lot is
asked of pro players champions are
continuously added and those new
champions often have kits far more
complex and versatile than their
predecessors mechanical prowess is the
expectation now but there are still
standout ezreal players like teddy after
two years of struggle with the perennial
underdog jin air green wings teddy
stepped into bang's spot on skt and
continued his legacy of ezreal greatness
now we got baker in here the baron goes
the way of gentee but the cleanup is
coming in for t1 and more and more
stopwatches come through connor is just
going to go down and rascal is playing
an awesome game here
able to come back from this huge deficit
and now they got the combo again and
it's up on faker but teddy is alive and
teddy's trying to go 1v3 he gets another
one and he's got to get another reason
man teddy is so gigantic and despite
being expected and typically required to
carry gin air during those lean years
teddy still played a conservative early
game on the champion giving him the
chance to get to the late game and make
a difference for his team when teddy
gets ezreal he actually plays very
differently and
i sort of got introduced to how good he
was on the champion during the blue
ezreal meta right where he was playing a
lot more defensively and it was so fun
to be able to watch both him and deft
play against one another because deft
still very aggressive in lane still
plays very far forward even when he
plays ezreal and when they switch back
teddy has a much more subdued approach
and plays out the lane much more slowly
and then always just always manages to
deliver
later on in the game in terms of pros
there are few with a better record on
ezreal at the time of recording teddy
has a 68.2 win rate on 66 pro games with
the prodigal explorer boasting a 9.4 kda
and he's so into the champion he's even
adopted his hair
if pros like teddy and his predecessors
fell in love with ezreal it's not hard
to see why no champion before him and
perhaps none after gave an a.d cary the
opportunity to shine so brightly to make
plays that dazzled and defied
expectations that was a scenario where
he was probably dead in 99.9
of scenarios where
ultra prime played correctly
no
no way lw x that was sick
and for fans that skill expression is
exciting too but whether it's the insane
outplays ahmed's in the back of the base
he has a wave at his back door as well
and they're looking to make their way to
the quarterfinals do they run fast
enough
is the ace and the last hope of europe
is still alive or the champion's style
and confidence some people call me a
hero their word not mine
but it does have a nice ring to it
ezreal has clearly captured the
imagination of pro players and fans
alike but the ulti comes into power is
brilliant true chaparrazz comes down
that's gonna be the end of the trundle
this is ladies and gentlemen why you
picked the ezreal
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our twitter instagram
facebook and tick tock
[Music]